Hi and welcome to PianoTV.
I'm Allysia and today we're gonna do a Q & A, question and answer,...
...where I talk about a question that I am asked a lot by beginners...
...especially teenagers and adults who are kinda wondering...
...how long does it take to learn how to play piano pretty good.
The short answer is that, you're not gonna like it, it's a long time.
It's gonna take you a long time.
There's no way around it, you can't sugarcoat it,...
...it's not like there's a super quick fix about it, there's really not.
I would say that for the average person who practices like one hour a day,...
...maybe half an hour, depending on how strong your practice sessions are,...
...I would say it takes about a year or two to get to a level where you can play...
...you know, you can be like, "Hey friends, check out this sweet pop song I learned."
And that's not to say that you can't do good music beforehand...
...that you know, in the year or two that you're learning...
...that you're just learning crappy baby songs,...
...but to get beyond the point where you're just learning basic techniques,...
...it's going to take at least a year or two.
And well beyond then, you're still gonna be learning basic techniques too.
That never stops, it just gets a little more complex.